[موسيقى]
نعم لقد كانت لنا علاقات مع حزب روسيا
الموحده تعود الى عده سنوات وهذا صحيح
ولكنها علقت فتره المعقوله على اخر
اتصالاتنا روسيا غيرت بشكل جذري سياسيه
تجاه الديمقراطيه الغربيه
هو خطا كبير لاننا نتخذنا بوضوح المسافات
كرد على تغيير السلبي في سياسه روسيا الى
غايه سنوات
مفيدا محاوله روسيا الى تحالف مع بلدنا
اوروبا لكن للاسف روسيا تجاهل توقعاتنا
وانتظاراتنا ولذلك كان علينا اخذ موقف
[موسيقى]
ولا يوجد شك في ان مهاجمه روسيا لاوكرانيا
جلب مشاكل اقتصاديه لكل اوروبا ولذلك على
اوروبا التجاوب كجسم موحد لتقديم اجوبه
لمؤسساتها وللشعوبها وهذا بالتاكيد بحاجه
مبدا والديمقراطيه التي تميز قارتنا والتي
لا تلتقي مع خيارات بلدا قرر غزوه بلد اخر
حر مثل اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]